a heroes this is Stanley I hope you
haven't forgotten me
you better not have forgotten me we've
been together for so many generations I
don't want that to stop it I don't
concede you as fans like as the you as
close close friends I'd like to feel
that you've instead of me the same way
so let's think of it that we have that
relationship you're my friend I'm your
friend and one if you had anything come
between that that arrangement and that's
really all I wanted to say
[Music]
Stanly the publisher of Marvel Comics
has probably been in the comic book
business longer than anybody on earth
he claims that Guinness is going to put
it in the Book of Records but that's not
really true is it
well they very well might you know as I
had mentioned earlier I think that I've
probably written more stories that have
been published than anybody who's ever
lived not necessarily better stories but
certainly more stories a hundred years
from now if somebody should bring up my
name it if it would still be around in a
hundred years it would be nice if people
say jeez like I thought he was a good
writer his stories gave me a lot of
pleasure that's what people tell me now
and it's the best thing any writer can
ever hear when somebody comes over and
says I proceed I derive pleasure from
what you've written this is Stan Lee
coming at you want you to know Marvel
has always been and always will be a
reflection of the world right outside
our window that world may change and
evolve but the one thing that will never
change is the way we tell our stories of
heroism Holy Smoke I go out of town for
a few days
and when I get back I find out that
Thanos has destroyed everything all my
characters that's the last time I ever
take a discount vacation well
unfortunately it means a lot of new work
for me don't worry before you know it
I'll have our friends up and atom and if
I were Thanos I started having had it
down eggs so see earth it isn't a
one-man field it is so many people
contributed I'm just happy that I've had
a hand in all of this
and I'm happy that even after all these
years someone bothers to interview me
about it I'm really very flattered
[Music]
nothin that's your cue
I thought he'd be taller
[Applause]
[Music]
any questions yeah can I have my shoe
back
oh man I am so fired
look at mr. smiles over in the language
where's your wife oh man what a bless a
briefer this was aged for a thousand
years the barrels built from the wreck
of Kronos fleet is not meant for mortal
men neither was Omaha Beach blondie stop
trying to scare us
egg crazy firefighter chick at the spot
last night like fine fine pretty stupid
fine and it goes up to the bartender
goes look at the car line wait you're
sayin she's crazy-stupid fine right the
bartender's are all like yeah
crazy-stupid fine are you Tony
stank yes this is this is Tony stank
that is hilarious
before I was so rudely interrupted at
that time I was a Federal Express man
hey fellas hey wait where are you going
hey you were supposed to be my lift home
how do I get out of here hey RG I've got
so many more stories to tell our guys oh
gee
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you